construya un cuadrado inscrito dentro
del círculo para poder hacer esto
tenemos que recordar que como todos
sabemos un cuadrado tiene cuatro lados
iguales congruentes y que se intersectan
en ángulos rectos y también tenemos que
recordar que las dos diagonales de un
cuadrado serán bisectriz es
perpendiculares mutuas veamos si podemos
dibujar dos líneas que sean
perpendiculares y bisectriz es mutuas y
justo donde estas líneas toquen la
circunferencia ahí tendremos los
vértices de nuestro cuadrado
bueno pues tratemos de dibujar aquí las
diagonales perpendiculares y bisectriz
es mutuas lo primero que vamos a hacer
es usar la regla y dibujar aquí un
diámetro aquí y acá ahora lo que
necesitamos hacer es dibujar una línea
que sea perpendicular a esta y que la
dice que justo aquí en el medio como
podemos hacer esto ya lo hemos hecho en
otros videos en donde utilizamos el
compás aquí lo que vamos a hacer es
usar dos circunferencias iguales aquí
tengo una y me interesa que el radio de
esta circunferencia nueva sea un poquito
más grande que la de mí y circunferencia
original de manera que cuando yo tenga
otra circunferencia igual y la ponga
aquí en este punto como centro tengan yo
dos intersecciones en estas otras
circunferencias que garanticen que la
línea que yo dibujé uniendo ambas
intersecciones me genere una línea
perpendicular a esta de acá entonces
necesitamos otra circunferencia que
quiero que sea del mismo tamaño así que
la centramos aquí y ajustamos el tamaño
para que quede igual ahora la movemos y
la ponemos en este otro punto y aquí
tengo estos dos elementos que si yo
dibujo una línea recta que los toque voy
a tener mi línea perpendicular sería
aquí y la puedo extender incluso más
allá hasta tocar la circunferencia
original y este punto también
muy bien ya tengo mis dos diagonales
perpendiculares y bisectriz es mutuas
ahora lo que necesito hacer es unir
estos vértices de mi cuadra usamos la
regla para unir este punto con este
utilizamos otro segmento de línea para
unir este punto con este otro de acá una
más para dibujar este tercer lado de
nuestro cuadrado lo acomodó mejor ok y
el último segmento de línea para unir
este vértice con este otro muy bien y ya
tenemos nuestro cuadrado con todos los
lados iguales con sus lados
perpendiculares y con un ángulo de 90
grados